love and responsibility go hand in hand
in fact part of loving your child is to
give them responsibilities um and uh is
to to to help them become not just
productive members of society which you
know ultimately they will be hopefully
but uh just to help them become better
better people which is better for them
um and so it's it's true that when you
have a lot of kids then then naturally
the kids uh you know it's more
responsibility for you as a parent it's
also it also ends up being more
responsibility for the kids as well I'm
one of six myself I have six so I know
this but that is um that's a feature not
a bug this is one of the advantages of
having a lot of kids is that gives it
gives your kids the opportunity to help
around the house to you know they're no
they're not becoming parents but they
are uh to some extent taking on the
responsibility and the role of caring
for their younger siblings uh this is a
great benefit for them